gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
france 24 muy buen día le pregunto qué
podemos esperar hoy en eeuu quien podría
ganar estas históricas elecciones además
le pregunto si este año podemos
confiarnos en las encuestas ya que en
2016 el escenario era favorable para
hillary clinton sin embargo ganó el
ahora presidente donald trump
muy buenos días y bueno son dos
preguntas muy importantes yo diría que
hay un el 50% más o menos posibilidad
que tengamos una buena idea de quién va
a ganar y ese va a depender de algunos
estados que seguramente va a tener
resultados hoy día porque como bien se
sabe que algunos estados como por
ejemplo en arizona florida carolina de
norte y se espera que va a tener
resultados hoy día he contado todos los
votos cierto que ya han llegado pero hay
otros estados como pensilvania donde
podía ser muy clave que no vamos a saber
por varias días pues o si ganaba ya por
ejemplo florida es va a ser bastante
claro que en quién es el ganador pero
igual el sistema en eeuu depende que el
perdedor
cede cierto reconoce que el otro ha
ganado y en el caso de donde no
esperamos que se va a pasar y tampoco
con su padre pues hoy yo diría podría
ser que sabemos relativamente hoy día
pero va a ser en los próximos días y
seguramente cuando terminen contando
todos los votos incertidumbre entonces
reina hoy en eeuu le preguntó cuáles son
los estados asegurados que tiene cada
candidato y cuáles son los que están
técnicamente empatados
tiene tanta mente empata bueno y que
depende cierto conectamos de las
encuestas que estamos hablando hay
varios la gran mayoría la encuesta
demuestra cierto que es una de los
estados bisagra para silva como michigan
pensilvania y wisconsin se demuestran
cierto que vayan va ganando pero ese
margen de error puede ser demasiado
chico o demasiado inseguro se para en
verdad lograr que gane como sea en
general todo lo analista dice
seguramente pero hasta que se ve es
verdad
la encuesta que definen la elección no
se van a ver de decir